it's a real pleasure to be back at
my alma mater and very helpful
this building brings back traumatizing
memories of a bio exam where i was asked
to
draw out the calvin cycle and estimate
the number of hydrogen atoms required
for photosynthesis which i did not get
right
um
so today i'm going to share with you uh
some of the work that my lab has been
doing
in the past couple years to to really
try to leverage single cell sequencing
technologies and computational biology
um to understand both the basics of gene
regulation but also in particular
um one of my sort of
interests is being a faculty member
division of mythology understand better
the molecular basis of autoimmune
diseases
are my disclosures
so i'd like to start with this slide
that i think um you know has been
alluded to by a few speakers before me
but a slightly i'd like to show to first
year graduate students to convince them
that they should at least be aware of
single cell sequencing if not work on it
for their dissertation
um this sort of plot reminds me of what
happened with the human genome project
and and the scale of data collection for
genome sequencing um very similar now is
what's happening in terms of sort of
experimental throughput increases in
single cell genomics and so x axis is
year and y axis is logarithmic logarithm
of the number of cells that's been
sequenced
and so it's really not that long ago
that we were still mouth pipetting
individual cells and then subjecting the
cells to bulk into sequencing uh
workflows to get single cell sequencing
data um and but you know it's anything
that that sort of grows exponentially
there's been a number of transformative
technologies that has made um multiplex
highly multiplex single cell genomics
now possible
i think the the one that that all you
know many of us are now using in the lab
is actually innovative well not really
innovative but just commercialized very
successfully by a local company called
10x genomics
and that technology uh basically came
online in 2017 and most of us are still
using one form or another of this in our
labs
which is one of the reasons that 10x was
a 15 billion dollar company
and just to worry you a little bit uh
since you know i figured some of you may
not actually know the inner workings of
the tech and it's it's a little bit
important to certainly if you can think
about exactly how it works um for for
later on
um and so the way that the 10x
instrument works and
in some ways every single sort of single
cell sequencing approach is trying to do
is to encapsulate cells in some sort of
physical
compartment and that physical
compartment could be a microwell it
could be a droplet or it could be the
cell membrane itself and each of these
physical compartments is labeled by a
dna barcode which i'm illustrating here
as this sort of like circular barcode
around
each cell
now 10x
makes this microfluidic device and the
physics of that device is governed by a
poisson process
and so for the technology to generate
single cell sequencing data um the vast
majority
right of the physical compartment that's
that's actually produced by the
instrument
does not encapsulate any cells
okay so right to guarantee that that the
expected number of cells that get
encapsulated in a droplet is one
and so this actually motivated a lot of
the efforts in my lab to try to game the
system or to hack it so that we get more
efficiency right so there's a lot of
wasted reagents when you run a standard
10x experiment which gets you out about
5000 cells
and there's a lot of very clever
molecular biology that happens within
each droplet and so what you basically
get out is this giant matrix the number
of rows is equal to about 5000 like i
said recommended number of features the
rank of the matrix is roughly whatever
you're trying to profile so for gene
expression which is going to be the
majority of the talk it's about 30 000
um columns
another feature of that data is it's
incredibly sparse as you can imagine
it's very difficult to do some of this
molecular biology so you get lots of
zeros
and
any sort of
simple analysis of the data i think it's
pretty convincing that it's not linear
and so we use a number of different
transformations
that i'll be showing where you're trying
to convert some 30 000 dimensional data
data set down to two dimensions um the
most popular one currently is umap
so um and so this has been the workhorse
and lots of papers and published sort of
using single rna sequencing to
interrogate complex cell mixtures and
discovering new cell types and sometimes
new cell states
but what's really motivated some of the
work in my lab is thinking about complex
diseases like lupus which is a highly um
heritable autoimmune disease
that affects primarily women
um and you know for disease like lupus
it's probably not that we're not gonna
it's probably unlikely that we're gonna
discover a brand new cell type in the
disease but that there might be subtle
shifts in cell composition as well as
cell state
and so this is actually real data that
i'm going to talk to talk about in a
second but if you just plot a density
map of a two-dimensional embedding of
millions of cells from both cases and
controls
you know it's not like there's a brand
new population or an island here that is
only observed in lupus patients but that
there's enrichment of certain
populations and depletions of others
and so for us to estimate
right statistically changes in
composition or subtle changes in cell
state imparted by either disease
or also maybe genetic variation
you need more samples and so this is
what really motivate motivated us to
develop uh some new approaches
and what's challenging oh i don't know
what's going on here
what's challenging in using standard
singles rna sequencing on large
population cohorts is cost
and so a sim you know a standard 10x
experiment cost about four thousand
dollars about half of that is library
preparation and the other half is
sequencing
and so
you know how do we scale single cell
sequencing so that we can actually do
population scale or very large sample
size studies
um and so i'm going to first describe my
algorithm that we built and just show
some data
and we sort of figured this out in 2018
on a drive from mission bay to parnassus
that maybe there's enough genetic
information encoded in the transcriptome
of a single cell that we could just mix
cells from different people and increase
the throughput at least per sample
throughput of a standard 10x experiment
it turns out that that worked really
well
so what we now do experimentally in the
lab is you can take single cells or
single nuclei as long as it's from
genetically different individuals even
first degree relatives pull them
together prior to loading them into the
10x instrument
okay if you do that
and if you have the reference genotype
and genotyping is really cheap on an
array for all the samples in this pool
we wrote this piece of code the
algorithm is called the muxlet where you
can essentially very accurately assign
the each single cell back to the donor
of origin
and so you know
again like you don't really need that
many single nucleotide polymorphisms or
genetic markers to uniquely identify
somebody right it's about 20 and a
quarter of law and so really the
question is do you get enough
information in a single cell
transcriptome and the answer is yes you
get about 500 markers even in the most
shallowly sequenced data sets
it's five thousand sales per experiment
uh we right so we can get get to that
throughput in a second we usually target
five thousand cells per experiment yeah
how many individuals do you pull in one
of these experiments so we've pulled
anywhere from 16 to 20 and that's
experimentally limiting because we're
taking frozen cells bottom count and all
that
um there's somebody in michigan who
pulled 125 cell lines it works just fine
i was surprised that they did that and
but the algorithm works
all right um okay so i i think you know
maybe it's
pretty easy to understand that you can
increase the per sample throughput
but another feature with multiplexing is
that we could also increase the cell
throughput of the assay
um and and the way it works is you know
sort of in a room full of mathematicians
it's probably pretty easy to think about
this
but if you do have two cells
simultaneously encapsulating the droplet
and that rate increases as more as you
load more cells based on poisson
statistics
the probability that a doublet will
contain cells from two different
individuals
increases with the number of individuals
with multiplex right and so it's one
minus one over n
okay and so if we multiplex 16 samples
the probability that a droplet that
contains two cells and those two cells
will be from different people is
something like you know 95
which means that um you know we could
use genetics again to try to identify
instances where there's multiple cells
from different individuals encapsulated
together because they'll be increased
heterozygosity and other features
genetically that would make the genetic
profile of that doublet look very very
different from any known human being
it's really that second feature which i
we usually don't really talk about
because we were worried that 10x would
change our workflow and we can do our
experiments
that actually uh decreases the cost by
about five-fold on at least the library
prep but you still have the sequence
and a priori we wouldn't know um you
know we can identify droplets that
contain multiple cells but we have to
throw that data away and later on i'll
talk about approach sort of get some of
that data back
so in the published paper we show that
it's full increasing throughput for um
overall actually it's about 10 folding
increasing throughput for just the
library prep side it's very accurate and
it's applicable to all sorts of single
cell sequencing assay it's not just
single cell any sequencing but single
cell toxic or multimodality anytime
you're measuring some sort of genetic
information within the transcriptome or
the chromatin
of the cell you could use demux to
de-multiplex your data
importantly right it minimizes batch
effects also because now we can
randomize your experiments
okay so um so then we
try this out uh and so we sequenced
about 1.2 million cells and these are
all what blood cells or peripheral blood
mononuclear cells pbmcs about 5 000
cells per donor in a fairly large cohort
of about 250 samples
and it's 160 patients with lupus and 99
healthy controls and we did this over
about 20 batches
so here's what the single cell
sequencing data looks like on 1.2
million cells from blood each dot here
represents a cell and cells that are
phenotypically related to each other in
30 000 dimensional space or closer to
each other in these in this sort of
arbitrary two-dimensional space
of course you know blood has been
studied at nauseam and so we identify
the expected populations of myeloid
cells on the right and lymphoid cells on
the left
um and
what's going to be a little bit
different from what we're doing in this
study versus a lot of other single cell
sequencing studies is that we want to do
a quantitative analysis of the data so
it's not just like identifying new
populations
and to convince ourselves when we got
the data that that you know the data
single cell sequencing can actually be
quantitative
we did a very simple analysis which was
one of my favorite figures but never
really made it to the main
um which is we took the myeloid cells so
these four populations non-classical
monocytes classical monocytes
conventional and plasma citrate
dendritic cells group them together
and estimated composition for monocytes
and then we did the same thing for the
lymphocyte population
and the reason we did that is because
monocyte abundance and lymphocyte
abundance
are reported in an electronic health
record of each person when they go to a
doctor visit right when you do a
physical you get this complete blood
count
and so we can now correlate our
estimates of abundances for monocytes
and lymphocytes from single cell
sequencing taking frozen blood thaw
sequence multiplex demultiplex and then
do all this computational analysis with
what's reported in ehr
and so that's what we're showing here
and it's pretty good especially for
lymphocytes that correlation is about
0.99 0.98 actually for the monocytes
they're two outliers here but overall
again it's it's pretty consistent
um
our cohort consists of cases and
controls and of individuals of different
ancestry so we can now ask whether or
not there are differences in abundance
or composition
between cases and controls and we
rediscovered lymphopenia which is a
feature of lupus so lupus patients have
a depletion of lymphocytes or adaptive
immune cells
another point here is that when we're
thinking about compositional data it's
relative right so
you got
you get lymphocytes and monocytes you
have a decreasing lymphocyte composition
increasing monocyte composition is there
actually a change in abundance
or is it that
one of the populations is changing and
the other one the frequency just goes up
the answer to that is that lymphocyte
absolute abundance decreases monocyte
absolute abundance doesn't change
okay so just a huge caveat on what we're
thinking about compositional data that
we need to also potentially think about
absolute abundance
okay so that's great but it's not very
exciting if we can reproduce what's
already known of course what's great
with single single cell rna sequencing
is we can go back in and identify um
you know whether or not each of these
major populations is changing
and
in what we think we discovered this
hasn't really been reported very much in
lupus surprisingly is that lupus
patients have a depletion of naive cd4
t-cells in circulation and this again is
observed in both patients of east asian
ancestry as well as european ancestry
so now we can use single rna sequencing
to identify changes in cellular
composition between cases and controls
we can also look for changes in cell
state okay and so lupus again has been
studied for a long time and one of the
features about the blood of lupus
patients is that there's activation of a
gene signature that's usually turned on
in response to an acute viral infection
the type one interferon stimulated genes
and so if we just treated our data set
as though we had done a bulk rna
sequencing experiment take all of the
cells aggregate it all together and do
differential expression analysis with
dec2
we can't identify the same signature
that's been known for these three
decades so in lupus patients in red
about half of them have elevated
expression of these genes that are
usually turned on in response to virus
but what's great about single cell
sequencing is now we can identify
a heterogeneity in the response of these
genes in fact they're two different
clusters of genes that first cluster the
black genes are turned on in every cell
type about the same way and that second
cluster the blue cluster of genes is
only turned on in myeloid cells with the
igniting cells and so again this type of
information would be completely lost if
it did bulk rna sequencing
compositional changes changes in cell
state all from the same samples which
allow us to now compare these features
um and what we discovered is that the
more activated your myeloid cells are on
the x-axis the fewer naive cd4s you have
in circulation and so these two features
are inversely correlated with each other
which we think is consistent with the
piotropic effects of type 1 interferons
um
now this is a fairly large cohort and so
one of the things we wanted to do is
also to see if we can actually use
singles rna sequencing data
to now identify genetic effects that
might be cell type specific right
there's this huge conundrum in human
genetics which is everybody proposes
eqtl study or identified genetic
variants that are associated with gene
expression
if you look at g-techs or other eqtl
studies we realize that all the variants
that are eqtls are highly enriched with
g-wasps but they explain very little
heritability and in some cases the
enrichment is not even that great it
doesn't stop us from proposing it in the
grant but it's kind of a conundrum why
is that the case
so one hypothesis is that well maybe all
the genetic effects that are that's
modulating disease risk are highly
context specific and one of the contexts
could be cell type and so now we have an
opportunity to assess the genetic
effects across all cell types in
circulation
the other thing it's a little bit more
subtle point which is that maybe there's
actually a lot of plyotrophy right there
may be genetic variances associated with
gene expression that's that and that
effect is consistent across all cell
types
and that the variants that you really
care about are the ones that turn on
a cell type specific gene expression the
deltas
and so we devised a method with noaa
zaitlin and bruno the belu a ucla to
basically decompose our gene expression
profiles from nine different cell types
to a share component and a cell type
specific component and use each of those
features as our trait to map with
genetic associations
and when we did that for the share
component we discover what everybody's
already has sort of reported on which is
almost every single gene in the genome
is under some sort of genetic control so
here i'm sort of showing a modified
manhattan plot where each dot here
represents whether or not if there's a
genetic variant associated with
expression of a gene within about 100 kb
and so you can see that
you know there are lots of signals
across the genome
but now if we take that cell type
specific component we identify some
additional associations and those
tracks basically are are qualitatively
very similar for cell types that we know
are related to with each other and so
that gives us some confidence that we're
getting the right thing so non-classical
and classical monocytes have similar
profiles and then the two t cell
population cda and cd4s have similar
profiles
but to further convince ourselves that
we're you know this these delta effects
are real what we did is we went to um we
took a
a different data set where they sorted
for bulk
populations within blood and did a toxic
so look for cell type specific regions
of open chromatin and we asked whether
or not those cell type specific cis
regulatory elements are going to be more
likely to harbor genetic variants that
are associated with gene expression that
are also cell type specific and the
answer is yes so the b cell specific
cptls are much more enriched for regions
of b cell specific cis regulatory
elements for t cells nks myeloid cells
and so
on and then the last analysis we did is
we asked whether or not the cell type
specific system ktls can actually help
us explain gywa signals better
and to our surprise they really did and
also maybe this other surprise is that
if you take the share component in black
they're not enriched for juwas
associations
so
this might seem like it's a little bit
at odds with sort of gtex data but the
argument there is there's always one
dominant cell type when you when you
sort of profile a tissue
and where you're probably getting a lot
is just that cell type the the cell type
specifics is utilizing that dominant
tissue
but if you look at the cell type
specific components you can see that
they're highly enriched
for geos associations and in many cases
it makes a lot of sense
if you take alzheimer's disease which we
know is is um mediated by a cell type in
the brain that's very similar to innate
immune cells called microglia you can
see that the
igniting cell etls are much more
enriched if you take lupus heart disease
the b cell and the classical monocyte
etls are much more enriched and again
this is consistent with what we know
about the pathology of the disease
so this data is all public it has been
public actually about six months before
publication and you could download it at
the change zuckerberg
cell by gene matrix to play with it
um and so we've now deployed multiplex
english rna sequencing of at least rna
in my lab we're studying mostly blood to
a lot of other diseases
like many in room you know when the cova
pandemic hit we sort of try to
contribute meaningfully to to figure out
the pathology of covid and working with
jean-low and cast nova others we
discover that
cova patients have a deficiency in type
1 interferon response especially the
ones who end up in a ventilator and some
of them actually have auto antibodies
we also now um are starting a different
autoimmune disease called sjogren's
which is actually very very common
there's no treatments for this
um and in case you know we're also
studying some cancer patients who are
undergoing immunotherapy
uh boy it's surprising but there's some
populations of cells in cancer patients
they're just not seeing healthy controls
even prior to treatment so we have
perfect predictors of just sequencing
the blood of whether or not somebody's
going to have end-stage prostate cancer
and we're doing some healthy controls as
well with joseph powell's lab we
co-published
a paper where we looked at a thousand
samples in this case sequencing only one
thousand cells per per sample instead of
five thousand like we did it's also
about one point two million cells
and in my own lab we just finished
generating this data set of about 1.6
million cells and and now not just
looking at rna but looking at chromatin
accessibility or epigenetic genomics as
well
across four
ancestrally diverse populations so equal
numbers of europeans east asians
african-americans and hispanics
collected in san francisco
so what's next
um and so i think there's still sort of
another maybe a couple years left of
scaling left to do in single cell
genomics and i'm particularly excited
about approach called combinatorial
index single cell sequencing
and i'll just quickly describe sort of
two vignettes of
sort of workflows that my lab has
developed to leverage combinatory
indexing to increase throughput but also
to actually encode additional
information into into sequencing assays
um but basically the name of the game is
if you think about again going back to
this illustration of what happens in a
microfluidic device um the standard
recommendation right is you sequence
5000 cells you have a lot of empty
physical compartments
with sample multiplex single cell
sequencing we increase the throughput
but we have to throw the data away
because we can identify doublet but we
can't resolve the data what we want to
get to is something on the right
which is
make every single droplet productive
and
be able to resolve all the cells
encapsulated in a droplet even if it's
quadruplets triplets etc
so you know there's lots of clever
computational methods you could do here
but um what we did is is uh basically an
experimental approach where we barcode
in addition before loading cells into a
droplet we barcode with additional
barcode and so basically try to solve
the birthday problem right we add a
month barcode to each cell and then the
droplet will be the day barcode and the
combination will allow us to uniquely
resolve cells
the key when we're doing combinatorial
indexing is that we have to barcode
every molecule and that's always hard
as a first pass we we sort of it was
easier to barcode
surface proteins so we can take
antibodies and stick a dna molecule on
them and then for each dna molecule we
can kind of use a secondary hologram
that would encode a
a combinatorial barcode and so we did
this experiment that now allows us to to
sequence you know hundreds of thousands
of cells in a single channel of 10x so
remember recommended it's 5 000.
um in this experiment we got 100 000
cells out so it's about 20x increasing
throughput
um and we we kind of know
in the process of doing this we i think
we've also reverse engineered exactly
what happens in your 10x device
basically there's a saturation where
the maximum is about 50 000 droplets
will contain cells
and if you don't use that combinatorial
barcode and trying to analyze that data
it's just a blob right because you no
longer have single cell sequencing many
of the droplets will have two three or
four cells
but then if you try to then if you
analyze the data with that first drop
first
round of barcoding the combinatorial
index you can actually resolve all the
data and get back about 100 000 cells so
we're very excited about this approach
called cytoseek
the second is is to encode more
information right so we talked about
spatial genomics a little bit um what
we've built is a these hexagonal wells
each of them are barcoded with a spatial
barcode and we can take a piece of
tissue digested onto these wells
um and then do combinatorial indexing
get singles rna sequencing data back but
also now tell you within
the size of each of those wells where
that cell came from
and so these initial wells are about 500
microns we're working on getting it down
to 200 microns and down to hopefully 10
microns soon
and we're actually incubating a new
company at baker labs that's trying to
commercialize this piece of technology
called xyz
i got about five minutes um and i i want
to just tell talk about one thing since
i am in an audience of mathematicians
that we're pretty excited about this is
the first time i've shared this and so i
would love to hear some feedback
um and so we built a new method a
computational method called momento
um and
what we're trying to do now is is
basically be more quantitative with
singles rna sequencing data
and what memento is trying to do is it's
a hypothesis testing method based on
method moments estimation and efficient
resampling
to be able to test for differences in
average expression
the variability of expression and the
covariance between pairs of genes
and so the motivation for this is this
is actually data from our sjogren's
patients
it's very similar for lupus on the left
is something like about a million cells
from
you know 100 patients 100 controls
if you make this umap with cases and
control separately if you do the
experiments right you do multiplexing
there's no batch effects
there's no real difference qualitatively
right and imagine you know if this was a
genetic variant or eqtl you would not
expect eqtl to have such a large effect
on the rest of the transcriptome that
you would actually have two you know two
very different view maps from
individuals of different genotypes right
so i think as we get more and more
population scale sequencing data this is
going to be the norm um and not sort of
the exception anymore and so we're going
to need new methods to be able to
analyze these types of data and ask are
there differences in the distribution of
gene expression
and so that's what we're trying to do is
a hypothesis testing method for looking
at the distribution of gene expression
between two groups of cells
and with any hypothesis testing method
there's really two things you want to do
you have to estimate your parameters
really accurately or maybe not so
accurately as long as you can as long as
it's not biased
and then the second is that you want to
be able to statistically assess whether
or not differences in parameters are
actually significant
and so the first one i'll talk about
that a little bit and the second the
gold standard is to bootstrap right
especially when
the distribution the underlying
distribution is very difficult to derive
and bootstrapping from singles rna
sequencing data is really hard
especially if you think about having
millions of cells but we came up with a
really clever way to get approximate
bootstraps that i think will make this
all possible
another point is that now each group of
cells could contain samples from
multiple different samples so we
actually do some meta-analysis here
um and you know what's unique is is we
are working on on i'm going to show some
data on detecting differences in average
expression between populations of cells
but what's unique from singles rna
sequencing data is you also estimate the
variability or the spread of the
distribution
and then um the second moments right
correlations between pairs of genes
which you can't get from bulk rna
sequencing data
and so i think there's a lot of
opportunities to better understand gene
regulatory networks by s by looking at
um
by doing statistical testing on
variability and gene correlation which
i'm not going to talk about here
all right so how's the method work um
the two components are we come up with a
very simple estimator method of moments
estimation and that's because
we think well we're pretty certain that
the actual sampling process the single
rna sequencing is not a poisson it's a
hypergeometric and people never really
actually did this because it's really
much harder to estimate parameters more
hyper geometric than it points on
um but we figured out how to do that and
then the second is of course
well if you got a hyper geometric
well i don't know how to write down the
maximum likelihood equations and so we
bootstrap the data and we figure out a
really quick way to boost trap
um all right so the the estimation part
first
you know
the the big the biggest challenge with
single rna sequencing or any kind of
sampling approach when you're sampling
molecules on a single cell
is that there's incredible inefficiency
in the actual
sampling process and so we came up with
one parameter that we call mu
which roughly is equal to the the sort
of frequency of total molecules within a
cell that actually gets sampled from
your molecular biology as well as your
sequencing okay
and 10 is actually about right this is
what we usually do when we do singles
rna sequencing is we only sample about
10 of all molecules after we sequenced
it
and so how do we build an estimator
of you know where you could have a
variety of sampling efficiencies or
sorry i switched this but q is the same
as mu
and so for me it's actually pretty easy
it doesn't really matter what you do
poisson hypogeometric or even the naive
point estimator you'll get the same
estimate but for variability and gene
correlation it matters a lot what the
estimators are if you use naive
estimator you will underestimate when
the efficiency is very low um but then
actually approaches sort of what you
would get out of the hypergeometric when
the efficiency is high and just some
points of reference standard 10x assays
are less than 20 percent
capture efficiency so even for v3 and
then the latest smart seek 3 workflow
claims to be about 35
we don't really think it is but that's
where it would be right
importantly the poisson estimator is
always going to perform worse than the
happy geometric
and this is also true for gene
correlation that's all in simulation
right how do we know this is wheo
fish data
you know we actually count number of
molecules and look at gene correlation
here's a naive core naive estimator
and the
lens concordance to what's reported in
fish is 0.53 for the naive estimator for
about 20 pairs of genes
saver is a method that actually uses
imputation the problem with amputation
is that you're borrowing information
across genes right if you try to detect
a genetic effect on a gene borrowing
information will lead to some biases
it's pretty good but that means
concordance about 0.62 and here's
memento without any borrowing of
information and just modeling the
sampling process we think better we get
a lens concordance about 0.68 on
fish on fish data so we're pretty
excited about this this is the
biological proof that i think we got it
right
okay so um efficient sampling i'll just
quickly talk about this but basically
the insight is that the number of unique
expression values is logarithmic of the
number of cells so we don't actually
need to shuffle cells we just need to
shuffle the number of unique values
and here's the actual result if you
compared to two competing methods basics
and sc hot we can essentially uh
bootstrap a hundred thousand cells for
one hypothesis test
and or a million cells in about three
seconds
for one test so if you have lots of
tests like mapping uqtls for millions of
variants you need to parallelize it but
three seconds is pretty good
um
i'll skip this and just show one slide
on uh power gain so
we apply this to eqtl study the one i
showed earlier if you compare this to
pseudobulk memento has about 30 percent
increasing power and so here we
downsample the number of individuals
from 50 to 80 and then ask whether or
not we can recover the same ccptls were
detected in a cohort in 250 and you can
see a pretty good power gain from
memento compared to pseudobulk
and if you ask whether or not we can
detect more enrichment for regions of
chromatin accessibility that's specific
to cell types again even with the much
smaller data set not the 250 just the 80
we can identify the expected enrichment
um for the matching cell types
and also more enrichment for disease
associations than just doing pseudo bulk
so to summarize i think you know there's
some really exciting experimental
technologies to increase throughput for
single cell sequencing to now population
scales i know of several projects now
that's proposing five thousand ten
thousand individuals already the cost is
about six hundred dollars per sample in
my lab so this is totally doable it's
comparable to volcano sequencing
we think there's still a lot of work to
do to sort of analyze all that data
i showed a couple examples of how you
can look for changes in composition then
cell state and map genetic effects
associated with gene expression
i introduced quickly to approaches that
i think will scale single cell
sequencing at least by another order of
magnitude after that i think we're kind
of done and it'll be too much data we
need to think a little bit more cleverly
about how to sample cells
and that introduced a new method that
we're still working on but it's pretty
close uh where we can do hypothesis
testing i think you know correctly for
differences in mean variability and
correlation functions rna sequencing
data scalable to millions of cells and
thousands of samples
um and it's not on bar archive but i'm
happy to share this github repo if you
guys want to try it out
and with that i'll just leave my
acknowledgements slide up and take
questions
[Applause]
slightly over time so maybe just one or
two questions and then we can do the
rest over coffee
great overview jimmy the cancer blood
thing went by a bit fast so you'll be
able to reshape what your conclusion was
uh we don't know yet but we detect the
you know my way cell population and
prostate cancer patients that
we're having a hard time detecting but
it's not observing healthy controls
okay but does it tell you about the
phenotype like drug response or outcome
or something
and it's too small
yeah clinical trials are all water dirty
points
not clear
just quickly i like to say the
distribution is hypogeometric and not
the same
right so
we are not
we're purposely agnostic about the
distribution of transports within a cell
all we're trying to model is the
sampling process the sampling process
type this type of geometric
the distribution of transcript with this
output very well
correct
and that's the problem right because
you're always going to be sampling even
if you have a perfectly perfect capture
of transcripts within a cell sequencing
is still too expensive so that you're
still sampling and that's still a
hypothetical process
yes
and that's why we bootstrap right
because we don't we're not making any
assumptions about the underlying
distribution of transcripts within cell
and so that's an active layer area of
research as well right
we have a short break now